partout je me déplace j'ai vu direct sur
l'antenne alors que ce soit à
l'intérieur comme à l'extérieur dans la
petite ville de Saint-Hilarion certains
habitants du lieu-dit Le Fléau ne
décolèrent pas en cause l'installation
d'un pylône téléphonique de 30 mètres de
haut par l'opérateur d'infrastructure
TDF en mai dernier un collectif composé
de 19 foyers dénonce une implantation
sans réelle utilité à 300 mètres de leur
domicile il y a pas de projet quoi c'est
le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui la
mairie n'a pas dit bah tiens il y a un
besoin SFR Bouygues de s'installer il y
a possiblement des voilà des problèmes
de couverture en bas du village mais
rien ne dit que le pullone comme il est
installéa va permettre de répondre à ce
besoin de de réseau mobile en bas du
village qui nous soucie dans tout ça
c'est que bah la mairie n'a pas du tout
communiqué sur sur ce projet donc ça a
traité ça comme une déclaration
d'urbanisme comme une autre de son côté
le maire admet un manque de
communication mais se défend en
affirmant que EDF a construit le pylône
sur un terrain privé ces actions pour
l'interdire étaient donc limitées
car il n'y avait aucun obstacle légal
pour que nous l'interdions qu'il y a
d'un côté des gens qui demandent à avoir
du chant sur leur téléphone et de
l'autre qui ne veulent pas les pilones
voilà le maire est toujours obligé
d'arbitrer entre deux mécontentements
cet habitant t'affirme que sa maison a
perdu 10% de sa valeur suite à
l'installation du pylône et l'a mis en
vente son bien par crainte des dangers
potentiels de l'antenne sur la santé
humaine je m'en vais parce que personne
peut nous dire si les ondes sont
néfastes ou pas moi j'en suis sûr donc
pour moi enfin pour ma famille pour mes
petits-enfants les membres de 0 g en
action ont déposé un recours contentieux
devant le tribunal administratif de
Versailles les projets d'installation
d'opérateur mobile sur ce pylône sont
donc pour le moment gelés le collectif
espère que le préjudice esthétique
permettra de faire démonter la structure
pour par la société TDF affirme que
cette installation a été faite dans les
règles